[Music]
what's up fellow geeks zaki here with
geek culture and if you're considering
getting a pair of wireless earbuds then
you definitely need to check out the
sennheiser cx plus true wireless earbuds
the latest iteration of the cx2 wireless
earbuds now
with anti-noise cancelling and
transparent hearing now anyone familiar
with the sennheiser brand name knows
that they are well loved and has a long
history of plenty of great products
maybe it's the prowess of german
engineering
or perhaps substantial try and error
accompanied with listening to what their
buyers want regardless of what that
might be
how does the cx plus true wireless
earbuds stand up to their legacy
is it worth its 259 price point
let's find out before we get into it let
me know what are you looking for in a
pair of earbuds is it the price is it
noise cancelling wireless charging sound
quality let me know your answer down in
the comments and while you're at it do
consider subscribing and giving us a
like as well and be part of this lovely
awesome geek community let's start with
what comes in the box you've got your
welcome letter we won't be needing that
and a manual slash guide on how to set
up your wireless earbuds
now of course if you want more clearer
instructions then i suggest downloading
that sennheiser smart control app which
is available for ios and google play on
top of that is going to help you
download the latest firmware for your
earbuds so it is important that you have
it downloaded we'll talk more about that
later we've got various sizes of ear
tips from extra small small
large and mediums are on default on your
earbuds
so make sure you get those right ear
tips to fit
your ear canals you're gonna need a very
nice seal so next we have a usb a to
usbc cable personally i like that it's
this way most of my plugs are still
using usb-a and here we have the case
pretty slick huh
it's matte black with glossy black
accents on the rim here and the coolest
part is that it's not a fingerprint
magnet like some other earbud cases so
if you're a little bit ocd like myself
it makes cleaning very easy feels good
in the hand it's it's
surprisingly light too
yes it's made of plastic but it does not
feel cheap
and it's a very simple design we've got
a led indicator here for battery status
red being low battery so it needs
charging orange for charging and green
which we have right here for full
battery
and the back we have a usb c port for
charging as well now opening the case i
got to tell you guys
[Music]
this feels awesome now in the case of
other earbuds you know they kind of when
you move them around or when they get a
good shake they kind of go out of their
slots you don't have to worry about
these sennheiser cx plus man the magnets
are pretty strong so they fit very
snugly into the case
they're not going to come out you know
you're gonna you're gonna be so assured
that these earbuds are gonna stay
charged and intact
now the case and earbuds have a charge
of 24 hours that means eight hours of
playback time and 16 hours of on-the-go
charge in fact spending 2-3 hours at the
gym
plug these bad boys on and i'm good
nobody
nobody nobody is going to hold on to
earbuds for that long so we've come to
the best part of this
and it's putting them on it's very
simple take out the earbuds from the
case
plug them into the ears and do a slight
twist
same thing for the left side and you
hear audio cue saying power on connected
and i have to say
these earbuds they are so comfortable
and the fact that these earbuds are
light weight weighing at six grams each
on top of it it's black so you know you
got a complete stealth look it's ipx4
rated so splash resistant you can bring
these guys out for a dunk and it's not
going to be the end of the world so one
of my favorite features of the cx-plus
is the fact that it has touch sensitive
buttons on both sides it allows for
gesture controls so you're able to
control your volume if i'm gonna double
tap it's gonna fast forward to the next
track on this side if i hold it it's
gonna activate anti-noise cancelling
this side it's gonna be transparent
hearing and you can actually customize
the gesture controls via the sennheiser
smart control app it's gonna show an
easy guide on what all this gestures is
gonna do for you so on top of that the
sennheiser cx plus true wireless earbuds
comes with bluetooth 5.2 technology
which supports codecs like sbc aac
x and aptx adaptive so whether you're
using an android or ios device you're
gonna get superior sound quality so with
bluetooth 5.2 we gotta talk about
connectivity as well and i've gotta
admit i have not experienced any drops
or disconnections with this earbuds so
far
whether i'm connected to my phone or
whether i'm connected to my computer
it performs so so good so let's talk
about anc or anti-noise cancelling now
plugging in these earbuds and activating
anc
it's gonna leave out that unwanted noise
and once you start playing music
man do these sound really good there's
no sound leaks coming through the
earbuds and you're gonna get that
perfect seal so i have to say that the
anc really works well for these earbuds
that being said there's also a function
called transparent hearing so with
transparent hearing if someone is going
to walk up to you
let's say gerald wants to have a chat
with me i don't have to necessarily
remove my earbud if you're going to take
calls
it's
it's nice to have transparent hearing on
so that you can monitor yourself a
little bit and kind of gauge your volume
so you kind of know that you're not
going to be
shouting
at the gym
so speaking of calls we've got
microphones on the cx plus as well and
what we have here is the microphone
quality from the cx plus to my iphone
and we're gonna add that into the mix if
you're gonna have calls
if you're gonna have a zoom meeting
these earbuds are gonna do the job
so i have to point out that sennheiser's
primary focus is on sound quality and
sound performance so the fact that
they've added microphones is a huge plus
i would say that the sennheiser cx plus
two wireless earbuds are
one of the more smooth sounding earbuds
i've had in a while the base and the
mids are
slightly boosted but it's not overly
done
in fact you get some nice deep punches
on the upper base range
and the mids add gravity to the vocals
and once we get to the highs they are
pretty clean not too overly bright with
little to no sibilance so besides all of
that you are able to actually change up
and have control over how your earbuds
sound through the sennheiser smart
control app i just love how sennheiser
has made the ui so simple that anybody
can just
fine tune how they want their sound to
be to be honest with you there isn't a
whole lot i dislike about the cx plus
two wireless earbuds everything they do
they do it really well it's going to be
a great all-rounder for its price and
the features are more than enough for a
casual user with anc transparent hearing
gesture control and a polished app in a
way i'm surprised what sennheiser has
done to put so much features into this
product and they're just they're just
super fun to listen to all right so
we've come to the end of the video thank
you guys so much for staying with us all
the way to the end let us know in the
comments if you're gonna pick these up
for yourselves top of that if you want
to know more details about the
sennheiser cx plus true wireless earbuds
we have them in the description so do
check them out until then
like subscribe smash that bell icon
and we'll chat to you soon adios
muchachos